je vois beaucoup trop de gens autour de
moi qui se disent ouais je vais faire
une chaîne sur tel truc et c'est ultra
bien réfléchi c'est vraiment ils ont une
super ligne éditoriale ils ont des
projets pour 45000 vidéos et tout et ça
ça se dessine hyper bien mais ils le
font jamais bonjour à toutes et à tous
et bienvenue dans ce monde épisode de
vue gâteau même le podcast qui tentent
de découvrir ce qui se cache derrière la
vulgarisation sur internet
et aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
d'accueillir valentine de la chaîne
sciences de comptoir qui s'est orientée
au cours du temps sur la géologie avec
de très grosses vannes bien potache elle
nous raconte son métier de vidéastes ou
de youtube eux c'est comme vous voulez
elle nous parle également du journalisme
scientifique de la troisième saison du
vent texte dans laquelle elle a
participé
si vous ne savez pas ce qu'est leur
texte écoutez l'épisode précédent et
l'origine de son amour pour la géologie
c'est d'ailleurs par cela notre
discussion a commencé je vous souhaite
un très bon épisode
voyons ce qu'elle a dans le ventre et
elle me passionner les sièges avant tout
si on dit des choses qui ne sont pas
conformes aux lois physiques ont dit ce
qu'il veut dire des choses n'auront
jamais très remonté enfin pu commencer
dans le peut partir dans le vif du sujet
avec une question qui peut sembler un
peu un peu bateau mais je crois qu'il me
paraît un petit peu important c'est un
peu ton parcours quoi en fait et comment
la géologie un petit peu rentré dans
dans ta vie bah elle est rentré tout
doucement j'ai pas fait exprès elle
s'est un peu insinué dans ma fille ce
qu'en fait quand j'étais au lycée on
avait des cours de svt et la plupart des
gens détestait la géologie tout ce
qu'ils préféraient c'était c'était la
biologie et je faisais partie des deux
personnes dans ma classe qui n'était pas
dégoûté par la géologie juste elle mais
elle me rendais tiède et du coup par
défaut je me suis dit bon bah ça se
trouve comme je déteste pas ça j'ai
peut-être pouvoir continuer là dedans ce
que je savais déjà que je voulais être
journaliste scientifique et donc qu'il
me fallait un background scientifique
donc en gros je pouvais choisir la
formation de sciences qui m'intéresse et
je me suis dit tout ce qu'a souhaité
c'est cool mais par contre j'ai été
formellement allergique à tout ce qui
est génétique et biochimie genre
vraiment et du coup je me suis dit je
vais faire une petite voix je vais
prendre un raccourci enfin c'était pas
raccourci mais bon en gros je prends une
petite déviation vers la géologie pour
pouvoir passer un peu tout ça ce qui est
un peu ironique parce qu'après j'ai fait
un master de biologie évolutive donc là
j'en ai bouffé de la génétique et j'ai
dû rattraper les trois ans que je
n'avais pas favre s'est un peu costaud
pour le coup mais voilà donc en gros
pour résumer j'ai un bac s après j'ai eu
une naissance en géologie puis j'ai
bifurqué en bio donc j'ai un master en
biologie évolutive et après une année de
césure gérard master en journalisme
scientifique et comment tu l'as vécu le
la formation de journalisme scientifique
parce que c'est un je pense que c'est un
petit peu comme le journalisme certains
trouvent que c'est très bien les
formations des fois on trouve ça un
petit peu trop formateur trop formateur
ou trop alliés non qu'est-ce que tu en
as qu'est ce que t'en a retiré toi ben
j'en ai retiré que du bon après bon ça
reste tous les cours ne sont pas
forcément extrêmement intéressant mais
la plupart du temps vraiment j'ai appris
plein de choses
et justement j'ai choisi cette formation
qui celle de paris diderot je me
permettre un petit big up puisque
maintenant je donne des cours en plus ça
me fait de l'auto promo c'est une
formation qui est justement complètement
à l'opposé de
tout ce qu'on nous apprend enfin
j'imagine ce qu'on nous apprend en école
de journalisme
par exemple il ya un bouquin de
référence pour les journalistes c'est
les petits soldats du journalisme qui
écrit par un certain françois ruffin qui
explique comment ça se passe dans
l'école de journalisme où il est allé
effectivement c'est extrêmement formaté
on apprend à faire enfin dans son
bouquin ce qu'ils racontent en tout cas
je sais pas si ça se passe vraiment
comme ça mais on apprend à lire des
dépêches afp et enfin tu suis le fil afp
et après ce que tu fais en fait c'est du
bricolage cdu passe-plat quoi tu crées
pas vraiment de l'information tu vas pas
spécialement sur le terrain tout ça en
tapant vraiment des codes extrêmement
stricte de ce que j'ai pu voir dans le
bouquin après encore une fois je n'ai
pas fait ces formations là donc je peux
pas en témoigner mais en tout cas dans
ma formation s'était complètement à
l'opposé de ça c'est vraiment une
formation qui est tenu par des soixante
huitards et est du coup vraiment c'est
c'est beaucoup plus tranquille au
contraire il nous donne les moyens de
nous exprimer et d'avoir notre touche
personnelle et c'est comme ça d'ailleurs
qu'on est plus ou moins recruter il faut
avoir ce petit truc entre eux en plus
cette personnalité je sais pas comment
ça se passe dans les écoles mais en tout
cas dans le masters c'est c'était
extrêmement important d'avoir un certain
une certaine couleur un certain
caractère quoi donc j'en retire que du
bon de cette formation
ok bah parce que ouais c'est vraiment
j'ai même autour de moi même des
personnalités qui ont vraiment eu du mal
avec des formations de journalistes eux
mêmes dans la science quoi parce que
enfin finalement aussi c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser comment on
apprend en journalisme scientifique par
comment toi tu l'a appris en tout cas en
fait ça remaster qu'on fait dans un
deuxième temps donc en gros on a tous
une formation scientifique à la base des
fois non il y en a qui peuvent venir de
la com qui peuvent venir d'autres
horizons mais en général on a quand même
un background scientifique et là ça nous
apprend tous les outils de communication
de vulgarisation pour transmettre ces
sciences là pour faire exactement la
passerelle entre le monde des sciences
et la société donc nous apprend par
plein de plein de médias différents
comme on dit donc aussi bien la radio
que la vidéo c'est très appuyé dans ce
masters l'an passé un master audio
visuel et journalisme scientifique qui
met vraiment l'accent là dessus ça c'est
cool donc audio/vidéo écrit et et web
donc journalisme presse écrite et web et
les réseaux sociaux et tout ça donc
c'est assez complet voilà donc on nous
apprend des trucs et astuces qui nous
font appliquer après dans plein de
domaines différents
et puis on peut aussi bien aller
assister à un colloque et après chacun
doit écrire un article
et ça hein
exercice qui est relativement réaliste
parce que dans la vraie vie quand les
journalistes c'est le genre de truc que
tu fais aussi quoi tu vas en conférence
de presse suivant conférence tout court
ou en voyages de presse et après il faut
effectivement récolter des informations
sur place et après les traités et les
envoyer assez rapidement et c'est assez
étonnant d'ailleurs qu'on n'imagine pas
qu'ils aient des conférences de presse
dans le journalisme scientifique c'est
un truc enfin dans les grands médias on
les entend pas beaucoup on les voit pas
beaucoup ça c'est au nom oui ça se fait
beaucoup les conférences de presse même
dans le milieu scientifique ne serait-ce
que balla avec tout ce qui est vu avec
le coronavirus les instituts qui
s'occupe de ça comme l'institut pasteur
il faisait à bâle ii conférence de
presse au contraire pour tenir au
courant les journalistes et le grand
public de tout ça non non ça se fait ça
se fait pas mal même le che pas le cnrs
qui met en place une nouvelle structure
pourra gérer tout ce qui est éthique un
problème d'éthique et problèmes de
fraude scientifique et tout chez eux et
bien ils ont fait une conférence de
presse et du coup c'est là où en plus tu
rencontres teper donc c'est assez rigolo
qui rencontrent aussi bien des gens du
figaro que de la fp que de machin tu en
a qui font des petits enregistrement
audio après pour la radio tendent à qui
font des petites capsules vidéo fin
c'est assez cool de pouvoir se mélanger
comme ça avec ses confrères comme non
j'imagine bien toi quand tu allais là
dedans parce que du coup ce que j'ai
compris tu verras quand même beau temps
et tu bosses encore longtemps en tant
que journaliste scientifique encore à
côté de tes vidéos
oui alors ça il ya un petit changement
dans ma vie dernièrement
et ça c'est cool à la base j'étais
journaliste j'étais pendant deux ans
journaliste à sciences et avenir qu'un
super magazine ça s'est super bien passé
et à côté de ça je faisais mes vidéos et
en plus des cours à la fac et du tout
comme ça et des conventions et ça
commence à faire un peu beaucoup pour
moi et du coup je me suis dit et si chf
transformer mon hobby en métier et
réciproquement et donc maintenant je
fais des vidéos pour gagner ma croûte et
à côté je fais des piges mais c'est plus
un hobby pour le plaisir et je suis
assez contente de ce virage en plus j'ai
vu que tu est soutenu par le cnc pour ça
donc c'est vraiment félicitations merci
le cnc est arrivée à point nommé parce
que justement parce j'étais au chômage
et paf le cnc donc c'est bon c'est parti
je suis lancé là est en fait comment
elle est apparue cette parce que là on
maintenant oui dr activité principale
c'est la vidéo mais comme ans est venue
cette envie de passer par la vidéo
c'était déjà dans ses études ou c'était
une frustration par rapport à d'autres
médias où nous c'est devenu cet attrait
pour la vidéo et l'audio visuel de
manière plus générale en fait j'ai
jamais été passionné de cinéma comme tu
peux avoir des cinéphiles qui savent te
dire aux à tel plan il ya tel je sais
pas at-elle valeur de plantes elles
coûtent replongé de je ne sais pas quoi
donc ça je ne suis pas dans ce genre là
je suis même j'ai même une culture
absolument crasson en cinéma par contre
c'est juste le côté curiosité j'aime
bien un peu tout essayé de me j'avais un
blog avant ça me permit de de me faire
un peu à l'écriture après
j'aime bien aussi tout ce qui est des
saints donc j'adorerais faire des bd
scientifique et tous et la vidéo c'était
quand même un truc qui me faisait très
en vue depuis le début mais j'avais un
peu peur ce que j'avais pas du tout les
compétences techniques donc je me suis
dit ça je laisse dans un deuxième temps
quand je quand je ferai une formation
pour et là ça vraiment débloqué plein de
trucs parce qu'on a eu
ils ont plein de matériel à la fac et du
coup ils peuvent nous prêter même pour
nos projets perso donc mes premières
vidéos elles ont été faites avec le
matériel de la fac ça c'est assez cool
donc en fait c'est un média en plus à
apprivoiser et en fin de compte je
trouve ça assez cool parce que c'est un
truc qui est ultra complet et parce
qu'il faut être absolument polyvalent il
faut s'occuper à la fois du sont donc
c'est comme la radio de l'écrit parce
qu'en fait ce que tu racontes c'est un
script qui est écrit et si ton script
est mal foutu et ben ça marche pas et
après et tout ce qui est contrainte
technique de enfin tout ce qui est
vidéos et tout moi j'aime bien tout ça
tu vois le aussi tout ce qui est en
photo savoir connaître un peu les
histoires de focale de vitesse
d'obturation tous ces trucs là c'est ça
me plaît bien
et donc j'ai trouvé que c'était assez
complet la vidéo justement dans d'autres
vidéos bon y'a un truc qui est quand
même c'est assez remarquable
l'humour que tu un plan de temps
d'antenne haute et chroniques
moi je vais appeler ça des chroniques
notamment toutes les blagues autour des
deux soeurs jumelles
me phung excessivement gars est très
loin quelle blague
et en fait pourquoi il ya eu pourquoi tu
as voulu mettre cet humour dans la
géologie est ce que c'est parce que la
géologie tout le monde s'en fout je
design et ambiance parce que j'ai fait
aussi de la géologie
ben en fait c'est plus ma personnalité à
moi je suis du genre à à faire plein de
blagues surtout quand je suis mal à
l'aise c'est ma voie de sortie messi est
en fait ces blagues deviennent malaise
et du coup c'est encore pire puisque je
suis un cercle vicieux
mais à la base je faisais des vidéos
très sérieuse les pigeons il en existe
une immense variété pour jouer la carte
de l'originalité je vais vous parler du
pigeon des villes les initiés l'appel
kolumba livia ou pigeons bisets
ce que je me suis dit ça me sert un peu
de vitrines pro et tout si je vais être
embauchés après et j'ai des copains qui
m'ont dit pourquoi tu est chiante à
mourir dans tes vidéos quoi alors que
t'es pas comme ça dans la vraie vie et
du coup je me suis dit bon je vais
tenter je vais faire une vidéo en étant
moi-même pour voir et c'est la vidéo
ivre virgule l'allège des cailloux quand
je dis aux gens que j'ai fait des études
de géologie la première chose qui me
demande c'est qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont pas
rond chez toi et la deuxième c'est est
ce que les géologues laisse vraiment des
cailloux alors non seulement oui mais je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
et elle a plutôt bien marché et moi je
sais la première fois je me suis
vraiment amusé à faire une vidéo
vraiment je me suis marré aussi bien au
tournant que quand la montant après
parce que je faisais des petits des
petites blagues par dessus tout est
comme ça a bien marché et que je me suis
dit que la géologie c'était cool je me
suis dit que j'allais continuer là
dedans et j'ai eu des bons retours de
des spectateurs du coup voilà c'est
comme ça que tout est arrivé
donc c'est la faute du public est en
fête bat maintenant tu commences à un
petit peu à voir ce format très tournés
en même temps entre humour et vulgaire
maintenant comment tu fais ce dosage
entre blagues et connaissances c'est
marrant parce qu'on dirait que jean il
ya un savant dosage
non parce que les prochaines vidéos que
je prépare là c'est au contraire givet
fulci de postes et un moment je me suis
dit bon l'important c'est de faire
rigoler les gens mais qu'ils apprennent
quand même quelque chose et là
maintenant c'est un peu yolo c'est juste
si rigole tant mieux et en fait j'ai
souvent des commentaires de gens qui me
disent j'ai dû regarder la vidéo trois
fois pour essayer de comprendre de quoi
tu parles est tellement je rigolais et
essaye c'est la plus belle chose qu'on
puisse me dire en fait donc je sais pas
si c'est le meilleur format pour
transmettre des connaissances mais en
tout cas je rigole bien on marque c'est
le principal
en vrai parce qu'on voit qui a une bonne
humeur communicative et c'est hyper
plaisant et c'est rafraîchissant aussi
dans le milieu scientifique sur youtube
je trouve merci mais alors être un petit
peu dans les milieux universitaires en
tout cas j'ai vu pas mal de gens qui
critiquent est un petit peu cette
vulgarisation qui a tendance un petit
peu à faire des blagues comme si le
sujet en fait n'était pas assez
intéressant lui même qui va les faire
des blagues
est ce que toi tu as reçu des critiques
par rapport à ça sur le fait que tu
utilises une forme d'humour que ça on
dépasse cette matière si sérieux que ça
ne donnait pas son prestige quoi
j'en ai pas eu du tout mais en même
temps peut-être juste qu'ils commandent
pas sur mes vidéos par contre les
commentaires que j'ai c'est plutôt ses
blagues là elles sont pas très safe tôt
réfute aurait pu éviter la blague
antisémite que tu as glisser un moment
enfin de ce jour 2 en même temps au
montage je me dis bon allez ça va passer
et en fait tout le monde se rend compte
de cette blague là mais au contraire les
retours que j'ai des géologues que j'ai
pu rencontrer ils sont plutôt contents
parce que ça ça dédiabolise une matière
qui est vu comme étant plutôt chiant et
du coup pour l'instant ça va
après je fais très attention à pas dire
de bêtises dans mes vidéos parce que
sinon effectivement on risque de
m'attendre au tournant ce qui est tout à
fait normal mais voilà donc comme l'a
dit il ya comme une forme de pression
quoi finalement quand même
après web à nantes à une communauté de
relecteur de chercheurs autour de toi
pour relire un petit peu les scripts ou
tu fais des soli de recherche et des
multiples vérifications bajeux j'essaye
de faire les deux justement et oui je
commence à me faire un p'tit un petit
pool d'experts
donc ça c'est cool des gens même que je
connais ni d'eve ni d'adam mais j'ai le
courage d'aller les contacts en disant
bonjour chaîne vidéo sur tel truc il ya
un peu le risque qui t'envoient chier
parce que bon c'est pas tu fais des
vidéos dans ta chambre ou quoi c'est
faux mais c'est l'image qu'ils peuvent
avoir mais n'ont pour l'instant j'ai
vraiment que des bons retours de
chercheurs qui sont absolument ravis de
pouvoir vérifier que je dis pas que des
conneries quoi donc ça c'est assez cool
je leur suis extrêmement reconnaissante
l'inde est en parlant des retours je
voudrais un type à aborder un autre
sujet parce que tu es là la première
femme à passer dans l'émission schiavi
présentation un petit peu la marraine de
l'émission comment tu vis toi c'est
finalement cette expérience de bidasse
tentant femme est ce que tu as des
retours là dessus
des fois qu'ils peuvent être
complètement désobligeants complètement
à côté de la plaque il parle pas du tout
de la vidéo en fait l'équipe parle de
toi en tant que femme quoi alors il y en
a quelques-uns mais franchement c'est
très très ponctuel ça arrive pas souvent
et c'est toujours bienveillant sa part
d'une bonne intention même si parfois
c'est très maladroit mais franchement ça
va on est on est loin du harcèlement
j'ai beaucoup de chance parce que ça
dépend complètement des gens il y en a
qui prennent extrêmement cher mais il y
en a qui sont complètement épargnés et
ma théorie là-dessus c'est que fin mon
hypothèse parce que si je veux des gens
qui passent par là des philosophes ou
des scientifiques vont être contents
donc mon hypothèse c'est que ça dépend
extrêmement de ta communauté et donc des
gens qui te partage et les gens qui me
partage ont eux mêmes un public qui est
extrêmement bienveillant et du coup j'ai
pas j'ai pas spécialement ce problème
croît donc j'ai beaucoup de chance de ce
point de vue est ce que tu as une
appréhension par rapport au fait que si
la chaîne continue à avoir de plus en
plus de visibilité il puisse y avoir en
même temps ce genre de commentaires
désobligeants qu'ils puissent à terme
augmenter aussi proportionnellement est
ce que c'est un truc qui tangue waes un
peu ou kit stresse un peu bas c'est vrai
que ça reste un peu toujours dans un
coin de la tête
c'est sûr parce qu'il suffit d'un
partage d'une personne et ça peut mal
tourner quoi c'est sûr mais donc
évidemment ça reste un peu en tâche de
fond mais bon faut pas faut pas
s'arrêter là il faut pas laisser la peur
de freiner non plus la devanture
parce que au début de ma chaîne j'avais
un peu peur de ça et puis je me suis
lancé et je suis absolument aucun regret
et je me suis rappelé que j'avais une
autre chaîne que j'avais des années où
je sais où je faisais des trucs un peu
plus perso je n'en dirai pas plus
des gens qui vont faire des recherches
bizarre prêt et j'ai jamais eu que des
commentaires extrêmement bienveillant et
sympathique et donc je me dis que ça va
ça vaut le coup de tenter
voilà je sais pas trop où j'allais avec
cette race alors on va aborder un petit
peu un sujet d'actualité alors alors on
enregistre et aussi alors vous allez
écouter cette émission dans la première
épisode j'avais reçu real myope
producteurs du vortex et j'y reviens tu
peux parler avec toi de te souviens
alors non
j'ai des dossiers dans ce pas c'est faux
c'est faux je précise c'est faux c'est
pas genre de blagues à faire en ce
moment par des oui mais quel souvenir tu
en gardes en fait de cette émission
parce que ça change complètement de ce
que tu fais ben franchement je regarde
une un super souvenir parce que l'équipe
de tournage était absolument génial on
s'est vraiment bien marrer à le faire et
c'était vraiment cool et la preuve c'est
qu'on a remis ça l'été dernier on est
allé tourner une saison d'été avec plein
de gens et c'était hyper cool donc
vraiment je recommande
j'espère que les vidéos seront aussi
bien que ce qu'on espère j'sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais on a plusieurs
façons de rire comme les scientifiques
adore ranger les choses c'est leur côté
marie condos ils ont rangé ses rires en
plusieurs catégories
d'abord le rire authentique et spontané
comme moi qu'on appelle le rire du chêne
et ensuite tout le reste bien merci les
mecs on sait où on va on peut se douter
avec le trailer qui est déjà sortie qui
va y avoir un petit peu de fictions
qu'est ce que est ce que ça fait quelque
chose de faire un petit peu de deux
chroniques fiction va dire en bulgare
est ce que ça tape poser des soucis ou
où c'était un petit challenge qui t'a
bien stimuler pour pour la création à
base de fer de l'acting quand on n'est
pas comédien c'est sûr qu'il ya un petit
côté et quelques appréhensions oui mais
écoute on y est allé et puis ça se
passait dans une bonne ambiance et puis
bon après quand on se voit c'est
toujours difficile d'avoir un avis à peu
près objectif sur sa personne mais
j'espère que les gens sont tolérants
c'est ce qu'ont indulgent avec nous non
mais globalement je pense ça s'est bien
passé en tout cas c'était très rigolo à
faire je le doute et par rapport à cette
saison du vortex en tout cas que celle
qui est déjà disponible
cette approche transdisciplinaire
comment tu l'as vécu cette manière de
bosser à plusieurs pas ce que c'est on
dirait c'est une plus qu'une vidéo
collaboration c'est vraiment une série
de collaborations toi comment tu l'as tu
l'as vécu de notre manière de travailler
bah c'était très cool c'était ça demande
un effort supplémentaire parce qu en
fait j'étais un peu la caution sciences
dures de de l'avant ce qu'en gros il ya
angle droit qui fait du droit comme son
nom l'indiqué il ya un créatif qui fait
un peu plus tout ce qui est marketing
économie et puis il ya montée qui fait
d'eux
un moustique avec fait de la
linguistique qui s'est ouvert un peu
plus aux sciences sociales sur sur cette
saison et moi du coup je remplissais un
peu la case sciences dures s'il ya bien
un petit complément à apporter sur
certains sujets et franchement c'était
cool parce que ça rejoint un peu mon
activité journalistique qui consiste à
traiter d' absolument tout ce que je
suis généraliste donc je suis pas
spécialisé dans un une thématique donnée
et donc c'est assez cool de pouvoir
mettre le nez dans plein plein de sujets
différents aussi bien de la botanique
que que la géologie de l'antarctique que
enfin tu vois plein de sujets
extrêmement variés c'était très très
cool et cette approche
interdisciplinaire je trouve ça vraiment
sympa ce qu'en fait on a on la construit
on a construit deux épisodes autour de
ça c'est pas genre un petit truc
accessoires qu'on voit en passant dans
les vidéos c'est vraiment on s'est réuni
et chacun a dit bon je voudrais traité
tel était le sujet ça pourrait être cool
et chacun avait pensé un peu en amont
comment les autres pouvaient intervenir
et les autres même pouvait proposer des
idées et dire ah bah ça ça recoupe
exactement tableau de sujets tout ça et
c'est comme ça qu'on a construit nos
collègues et nos épisodes et donc je les
trouvais ça assez sympa comme méthode de
travail
c'était cool on voit vraiment les
interactions entre les gens quoi et ça
apporte quelque chose au propos c'est
que c'est un des vrais pourra fort de
l'émission tout cas en tant que
spectateur c'est que on sent qu'il ya
une vraie alchimie en tout cas une vraie
bonne ambiance qui se crée que tout est
fait très naturellement
même si tout est très écrit très
préparée à l'avance ans organique n
spontanéité dans la manière de faire et
que c'est pas des collaborations forcé
en mode il faut trouver absolument un
point d'attaché pour pouvoir faire
participer tel vidéaste c'est super
agréable à avoir en tout cas merci
non effectivement les colobes alors les
colobes sont pas spécialement écrite
enfin avant les prépare mais sur le
moment c'est plus de l'impro ou fait
plusieurs reprises et tout est et ça
permet justement d'avoir un peu cette
spontanéité et tout et je trouve ça
vraiment cool et par contre quand tu
disais qu'on consent la bonne ambiance
entre les gens c'était assez délicat
parce que notre saison on est censé se
détester et dans la vraie vie c'est pas
vraiment ça et du coup il y avoir un peu
une une sorte de de dissonances entre
les moments où la caméra tourne et on
on devait s'envoyer défiant et les
moments et en même temps on fait des
collabos ensemble et tout et j'espère
que me sentir un peu cette complicité
c'était pas facile de jongler avec tout
ça surtout quand on est comédien amateur
mais j'espère que ça rendra bien on sait
pas d'où de là dessus façon les gens ont
déjà vu auront déjà un avis dessus
à mon avis qui sera quand même très
positif bon je compte sur eux il a
intérêt à être positif sinon je les
inscrit en fac de géologie sa part
conserve ont compliqué les pauvres
safran ce qui va leur arriver
c'est ça les trois ans je précise on ne
va pas tarder à finir les missions des
petites questions comme ça un petit peu
pour ouvrir sur la suite déjà est ce que
toi tu avais encore d'autres projets à
part le bon déjà on sait qu'il ya deux
saisons du vortex dans lequel tu vas à
paraître fou mais est-ce que tu as
encore des petits projets à droite à
gauche tu prépares déjà ta rentrée je
suppose à mon avis n'est et bah je vais
participer au festival frames à avignon
et cette année ils font qu'ovide oblige
il faut une édition un peu spéciale avec
une partie il fait un french tourist
balade un peu en france ils vont voir
des vidéastes et après une partie en
live qui sera retransmis en direct sur
leur chaîne youtube je crois avec des
conférences des trucs comme ça donc je
participe à cette chose ça va être cool
et puis le reste j'ai essayé de vraiment
mettre le paquet sur sur ma chaîne et
puis il ya plein de collègues qui sont
prévus et du tout comme ça donc ça va
être cool et plein de blagues de mauvais
goût
enfin est ce que toi pour un petit peu
ouvrir sur ton domaine finalement que tu
mets sur tachella la géologie ce que tu
as des des ouvrages des documentaires
que que tu voudrais conseillé des
produits qui pour aller un petit peu
plus loin dans cette belle matière cette
belle discipline qu'est la géologie ya
un premier bouquin que j'aime beaucoup
qui s'appelle la terre à l'oeil nu qui
est édité aux éditions du cnrs qui est
hyper bien parce qu'ils veulent garry's
hyper bien plein de sujets de qui
traverse absolument tout la géologie
aussi bien l'étude des autres planètes
que
la sismologie de tous comme ça donc
c'est vraiment hyper hyper intéressant
et puis la mise en page est juste
complètement dingue
enfin des infographies de malades et/ou
c'est vraiment cool c'est un bel objet
comme on dit et sinon il ya un autre
bouquin qui va devenir ma bible qui
s'appelle le guide du géologue amateurs
il est paru chez dunod et leye nouvelle
version qui est paru il ya pas longtemps
d'air et c'est hyper bien parce que
c'est le genre de truc que tu peux
emmener en randonnée ou en balade et ça
te permet de comprendre ce que tu vois
en fait quand tu te balades de savoir
identifier des cailloux des trucs comme
ça et avec un peu de baghran aussi un
peu de ça tu expliques les bases de la
minéralogie des différentes formes que
pas voir les cristaux les trucs comme ça
et donc c'est vraiment cool et et je les
vends pas super bien mais vraiment c'est
des bouquins très intéressant et pas
spécialement du tout pour spécialistes
donc c'est pour s'ouvrir à la géologie
pas parfait mais je les mettrai dans le
dans le descriptif du podcast mettrait
des liens pour se les procurer si ça
intéresse les gens si les gens sont
assez fous pour s'intéresser à la
géologie
mais des liens fils si seulement on
refera moite mois sur les royalties
[Musique]
commence à moi de moi tu es on
s'arrangera après et enfin pour
retourner un petit peu dans la séan
vulgarisation quels sont les buts
égalisateur les vulgarisatrice qu'il
atteint ce pire en ce moment dont tu
apprécie particulièrement le travail là
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait ma nombril
de c'est une autre histoire
évidemment sinon il ya les abbés l'eau
qui fait plein de choses pour plein de
chaînes et
et pour sa chaîne qui c'est qui qui
vulgarise ça plein de sujets à la base
elle faisait pour le sénat elle faisait
des vidéos qui s'appelle zeste de
science et pseudo-sciences merci quand
j'ai pu oublier ça et voilà et là
maintenant elle participe à une série de
vidéos sous-marines avec balade mental
qui s'appelle les monde du dessous et
elle va faire un truc aussi ailleurs
mais je sais pas si je peux en parler et
donc c'est hyper cool ce qu'elle fait
elle fait aussi une chaîne qui s'appelle
avides de recherche
elle fait elle faire 1 milliard de trucs
je sais pas comment elle fait voilà
sinon il ya sébastien carassou bien sûr
qu'ils parlent extrêmement bien de tout
ce qui est espace astronomie tout sa
chaîne c'est le sense of wonder
je pourrais continuer longtemps comme ça
je sais pas il ya stupide economics il
ya un monsieur filles homos fabius qui
parle de tout ce qui est heureux science
slash biologie slash philosophie qui a
fait toute une série sur la philosophie
de la morale et ses origines évolutif
tout ça enfin c'était grave c'était son
sujet de thèse
bah je peux finir par copains du web qui
est un peu mon idole absolue vulgarise
la technique si j'ai bien compris c'est
un peu difficile de lui mettre une
étiquette y fait tellement un milliard
de truc et c'est hyper cool à chaque
fois enfin vraiment c'est un un modèle
absolu entre sedan en termes de
d'écriture de scénarisation de montage
de d'effets spéciaux face à un duo
évidemment je suis absolument fan qui
n'est pas fan de copains du web kinsey
c'est la vraie question
je mettrai aussi tous les liens de ces
personnes de qualité dans dans le
descriptif du podcast bien écoute je
pense qu'on va on va s'arrêter là pour
pour cet instant merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris un petit peu de ton temps pour pour
participer c'est un petit peu pour un
petit peu raconté david vulgarisatrice
finalement la merci à toi et on écoute
si tu as un dernier petit conseil pour
ceux et celles qui vous a peut-être se
lancer c'est toujours un petit peu éculé
comme comme question encore une fois
mais bon je pense que ça sert toujours
oui j'ai un conseil
le conseil s'est lancé vous je vois
beaucoup trop de gens autour de moi que
ce soit mais ces étudiants oui je peux
dire ce genre de phrase que cet homme m
mes amis qui se disent ouais je vais
faire une chaîne sur tel truc et c'est
ultra bien réfléchi c'est vraiment ils
ont une super ligne éditoriale ils ont
des projets pour 45000 vidéos et tout et
ça se dessine hyper bien mais ils ne
font jamais parce que il bute sur la
première vidéo il n'arrivait jamais à
arriver au bout parce que je ne sais pas
il considère que la technique c'est une
montagne absolument surmontable de
compétences à acquérir et ou alors faut
vous dire que la première vidéo vous
sortirez ce sera pas la meilleure mais
c'est normal
à chaque fois que je sors une vidéo je
me dis que la suivante sera meilleur et
c'est ce qu'il faut parce que sinon ça
veut dire que vous stagner et du coup
lancé vous n'ayez pas peur de l'enceinte
de publier un truc même s'il n'est pas
absolument parfait vous pouvez aussi
contacter des gens qui sont déjà dans le
game et qui pourrait vous donner des
retours sur vos vidéos pour vous
améliorer
voilà il s'était pas à me contacter en
dm si vous voulez ce genre de de retour
et si vous voulez plein de conseils en
thelle intéressant il ya la chaîne de
viviane de syllabus qui s'appelle
syllabus plus où elle raconte les envers
de son cheminement pour la vulgarisation
et pour faire des vidéos et c'est hyper
intéressant et vous pouvez choper plein
d'astuces là dedans voilà c'est mon
dernier ma dernière recommandation et
ben écoute superbe à merci beaucoup
merci encore beaucoup pour merci à toi
on va donner de ton temps et puis à
priori delà actuellement une chance une
petite musique en train de couper des
options à mesure parce que j'entende
parler beaucoup trop
[Musique]